6:30 a.m. fs1 every single day I was
getting up early for you hey I mean
listen getting up sucks no matter what
time you get up like if I had to get up
at 8:30 I'd want to sleep longer that's
I get up at 3:30 every day that ain't
great but I mean it's it's a great job
so you deal with it it's during the NBA
playoffs these 10:30 start times I'm
glad they're done man because the game
ends at 1:00 and you sleep for two and a
half hours like you go to bed 11:30 get
four hours sleep taking nap during there
you make a work going about it wanting
getting up at 3:30 that ain't fun well
not I mean I got a great job I mean you
know the the finals those games start at
9:00 yeah but that's better than 10:30
that's true there's these damn Portland
games are starting to 10:30 a lot of the
Golden State game starting 10:30 I mean
that that's an outrage yeah the the
early the skip and Shannon show
undisputed starts at 6:30 as well they
also get up around 3:30 but they the
games in three hours are they live in LA
like those the latest game starts at
7:30 at night so it's very different but
whatever it's no problem do you have a
daily routine down yeah I go to bed
around 11:30 or 12:00 unless these
stupid games are on so late and then I
do not eat until after the show I eat a
giant lunch I'm looking forward to that
today it'll be Chipotle uh and then I
pass out until it's time for me to go
pick up my kids from school so that's
what I do that's my routine and then I
check I see has Chris Mannix picked a
new team to win the eastern half well it
to be fair like we are now four games
away from my original team getting to
look I'm not gonna do it I am NOT going
to pick the Boston Celtics why would you
already not at three time no I maybe
three depends I was ahead of the curve
in November in November I said the
Celtics I wrote that long column the
Celtics are going to win the Eastern
Conference
if Kyrie were healthy yes oh yeah they'd
be clean without Kyrie oh okay I mean
that's it's fun to play the make-believe
game
Kyrie wouldn't be much better than Terry
Rozier has been now Kyrie is a better
player but when you incorporate the
defensive end of the ball I don't know
that he'd be much better well you're
also so holy you're at you get you
wouldn't just take away Terry Rozier
though you'll be adding Kyrie to
terrorise here and flushing on a bench
that's seven deep right now yeah I mean
theoretically I see what you're saying
Larkin wouldn't be in the rotation
Larkin that's fair point I now I do
think this because we living on Kairi
hater and I'm not
I think Kyrie next year I would would be
the heavy favorite four six man of the
year I mean I think he's gonna be Kyrie
coming off the bench with Rogier scary
Terry being your starting point guard
scoring off the bench like a rich man's
Nate Robinson and I see nothing wrong
with that I don't think you can do that
neither do you I mean I don't know I'm
just throwing it out there I mean I
don't know if you want to mess with what
works but that's fine I think you got a
trade Tara's here oh oh the untradable
Terry Rozier not you I'm not talking
about you the of for a long time that
was a punch line and by the way Danny
Ainge improving right yeah people were
wondering what why do you want this
Terry Rozier kid from Louisville people
thought he was over drafted when they
took him it's true the team's it's true
the team's tried to acquire him many
times and Danny has been a know largely
untouchable and hey listen they he saw
something that I didn't see I didn't
think Terry Rozier could ever do this
over a dozen games stretch in the
regular season let's let's the
postseason he's been rose years been
awesome man
and he's like eat tough guy guy from
Youngstown Ohio with wings tattooed on
his neck like that's not a guy you mess
with if you had to choose between Rozier
and Marcus smart for the next four years
if you could only sign one of them would
you take the smart part of me says it's
obviously Rozier like all the advance
numbers say it be Rozier all the I test
things say it's Rozier but for some
Marcus smart is like some magical elixir
for this team I don't there there is I'm
a I sometimes to relying on numbers
there is no number that explains why the
team is so much better with Marcus smart
on the court than without Marcus smart
on the court it's like that intangible
thing that it does seem to energize his
teammates when he gets to a loose ball
or when he takes a charge and it doesn't
deflate them when he pulls up from three
as it wouldn't me if I were on his team
like he's valuable to them and I think
he'd be cheaper right I think that he
has specific value there that isn't
necessarily transferable the way Terry
root Terry Rozier is valuable in a
league that is the best it's ever been
at point guard he's proven himself to be
a starting point guard in this league at
least in my opinion well Marcus smart
has spiked his salary demands this
summer like if Marcus
if he went out in February and the
southest got bounced in the first round
his value would probably be X now it's X
plus something because of how he played
in that second round and how he's
probably going to play in the Conference
Finals I it's a tough call for me I
would probably take smart because next
year and follow me here next year it
feels like Boston could put out the kind
of death lineup that would rival Golden
State's because you could play Kyrie
Gordon Hayward Jason Tatum jaylen Brown
and Al Horford all together not for
entire games or for long stretches and
you can out score everybody so if I can
put that line up on the floor I want a
defensive weapon off the bench Terry
Rozier is a capable defensive player
Marcus smart is a great defensive player
so I want the defensive Swiss Army knife
that I can bring unto a court in any
situation I listen I think that's
excellent analysis I agree with you I
don't know if you want to build your
team for the only two games you're gonna
get to play against Golden State because
when LeBron goes to Philly like Boston's
here drawing dead in the East anyway
what am I wrong well I think you might
be wrong about LeBron going to Philly
but if you were to go to Philly like
this is well okay you'd never mind I'll
let you run no no no I just uh listen
that is I do have this question about
Boston okay just one how much better
would they really be with their stars
it's agent come on man they you I my
only thing is you can't have it both
ways in that the who said that they were
as interchangeable pieces as they've
been as anyone's ever seen it was said
last week I think by one of the coaches
that it almost feels like no matter
who's out there you are getting the
production of the guy who's in front of
them or at least 90% of it so I don't
think this is the typical team where
it's like wow we're gonna add Kyrie
Irving to this team because you are
getting 80% of Kyrie from Terry Rozier
like we're oh we're going to add Gordon
Hayward we're getting what 85% of what
you expected from Hayward from Jason
Tatum I think the I mean I think it's a
fair question will Gordon Hayward
like by will Gordon Hayward ever be
better than Jason Tatum and by that I
mean this I think I think we saw from
Paul George that type of injury you can
come back in a year but it usually takes
a
year back to get to your full strength
and by then Jason Tatum be in year three
and two you were right about Tatum like
I got to give you credit you were early
on it I was I was way off on Tatum when
they made the trade that was obviously a
heist now we look at it they got the
best player in the draft not named
Donovan Mitchell and some people say the
best player in the draft and they added
this awesome pick like that was one of
the best moves Danny Ainge has ever made
but like the and you saw it early you
said he thinks is a guy that can win
scoring titles they've me a 25 point and
I thought he could be an impact player
in these playoffs and I didn't exactly
and I was I whipped on that three times
because I kept saying it's the last
rookie to make a big impact on a playoff
to you well three guys did it this year
I mean Mitchell simin times 7 to the
rough second round and Tatum's been
extraordinary I mean seven straight
games 20-plus points the only guy is a
rookie to ever do them longer is cream
like I mean it's remarkable what he's
you you say though we're talking to Nick
right the coast - first things first on
fs1 he's joining us here Dan Patrick
show um you say would Boston be better
right now with those guys but again I go
back to the fact that you're not you're
subbing out you know I Kyrie for a Terry
Rozier he's not subbing out Gordon
Hayward for a Jalen Brown you move one
of those guys to the bench and one of
the problems Boston's had is scoring
droughts they've had three four five
minutes stretches where they can't score
all of a sudden if Jalen Brown is your
sixth man you can score more with that
second you're in Terry Rozier you can
score more now they're gonna have a lot
of problems next year I don't know it's
gonna be you're gonna have to see some
Brad Stevens wizardry for that to happen
next for it for things to work but you
get a stride Stephens real quick yeah do
you feel badly that you cost him votes
for well I think I I happen to believe I
don't wanna talk about this yesterday I
I have real reason to believe the reason
Brad Stevens was shut out by his
colleagues for coach of the year is
maybe justifiable bitterness from
coaches towards guys such as yourself
and myself the Talking Heads who act as
if Brad Stevens is a deity and and I
think there was some bitterness towards
the idea that Paulson had no talent like
you I had heard from people in the Liga
like listen Brad's a great coach but the
way you guys talk about him compared to
the rest of us is unfair to everyone
else that's the only Dwayne Keys a
winning coach to the years fine like
you'd make a case for it well Brad
Stevens
getting no votes to me that was
verification that there is a feeling in
the league amongst the coaches because
that's obviously not the media ward
that's the coaches right one the coaches
vote on that the coaches said let can we
just pump the brakes a little bit on
worshipping at the altar of Brad Stevens
now I still worship at the altar Brad
Stevens hi yeah I'm not gonna go as far
as your Twitter poll would rather have
him or any player in the league or
question but there's only well it's it's
it can't be LeBron though because it's
not gonna be because it's an expansion
team that's what I said in the front
it's an expansion - you don't want your
expansion team to go to the NBA Finals
in year one I mean there's 12 there's to
me a dozen players I think it's really
would you really if you're the GM of the
Las Vegas sharks or whatever and you're
saying like you can't you're building
your team out for the next 10 years you
don't take the honest or embiid over
LeBron well hold on maybe I would but I
wouldn't take Brad Stevens over okay and
more people voted that yeah there's a
dozen players I would take you honestly
I wouldn't take the player - I didn't
vote on that people going after me
saying I thought this is a ridiculous
poll I didn't vote I just put the
question out there and it's interesting
though if you're asking me like which
player right and I could have any player
in the league and I'm getting them I
don't have to worry about them leaving
right I'm getting them from now until
their careers over my hierarchy would go
Yanis one Anthony Davis - Ben Simmons
three embiid 4 and then at that point I
think I'd take LeBron because I think
he's got another three years three years
as the best player in the league and
another couple after that while he waits
on his son to get to the league where
he's gonna still be a top ten guy like
so I yeah I think that's a fair point
now I'm also a hugely honest man I think
Jana sees everything people are saying
Ben Simmons going to be different type
of player but taking over the league I
think be honest about to do well Ben
Simmons is gonna have to do it Jana
stand deconstruct his jump shot and
reconstruct it in a different way Yanis
right now has a clean-looking jump shot
Ben Simmons is all kinds of messed up
you think it's possible Ben Simmons is
shooting with the wrong hand since if
you think it's possible that Ben Simmons
should be shooting right-handed I think
it's switch like well but he is it's
something I'm gonna miss quote it and I
apologize he's like right-handed and
everything but basketball yeah yeah so
it's uh it's just when you're when the
shots that bad dude took fifty nine
shots in round two
ooh were outside of the paint only ten
were outside of six feet and he was two
of ten on those outside of six feet and
it's the problem in simmons is not even
it's not that he can't make a jump shot
it's that he won't shoot a jump shot
like you got it even if you're gonna
shoot 30% you got to be a threat to
actually shoot the ball they know he
won't do it I also talked to someone
that knows Ben really well that thinks
what happened in this round will be good
for him great they had this sense of
arrival before actually arriving and
this will humble them a bit 80% of the
mistakes Ben Simmons made in that second
round he's not gonna make him and make
him again those are mistakes you make as
young players
I thought the Sixers would take their
lumps in that first run against Miami
they were better than that they they
pushed through the rookie stuff and the
sort of the early young player stuff and
won that series this is where they took
their lumps but Oklahoma City did it all
the young teams did it to put a button
on what you said about Brad Stevens why
he didn't get the votes there a couple
reasons it definitely could be some of
the stuff that you talked about that
that we in the media put him up on a
pedestal justifiably in a lot of ways
because of what he's done with this team
his timeout plays are brilliant as we
saw that Philadelphia series one Dwane
Casey if he got all 30 votes I don't
think this would come up I don't think
we'd be having this conversation because
it's a one line vote you can already
board for one coach and Dwane Casey has
been a part of the coaching fraternity
for a long time he's been an assistant
coach a head coach
everybody likes Dwane Casey he's been
there and he deserves it for the regular
season he was great postseason different
story the problem I have is why is like
you know Doc Rivers getting a vote why
are Quin Snyder was not being that's my
listen it was a five line ballot Quinn
I'd be on my belt what's got it was
throw to my coach to you right so I
don't have a bra I understand all that
it was odd though that Brad Stevens was
shut out entire yeah it was really well
to this the the six votes that that went
to somebody other than 20k see there is
my where's my list if you don't think
it's Casey how do you not think it's
Brad Stevens given everything that's
going on in Boston right we'll take a
break we'll get to the Western
Conference as well Steph Curry vs. James
Harden Rockets home court advantage of
the star power Golden State getting that
wood Nick Wright
host the first things first coming up
next Nick's trying to go to the south
the game South the Cavs game one Sunday
and he told me during the break that if
he goes I mean Nick is a advocate for
LeBron how would you describe your I'm
gonna believe I let you believe I'm a I
would like to think I'm one of the the
only honest people in the media about
this there we go this I mean this has
been pretty obvious for the last couple
years that ever since LeBron completed
the greatest three-game stretch in the
history of the sport against the
greatest team in the history of the
sport to deliver his birthright to the
city of Cleveland he's been the greatest
basketball player we've ever seen how
people can argue otherwise but they
don't really mean it
they just do it because they think they
have to or they have a nostalgia bias or
they're I don't know some diehard Boston
fan I'm not certain but I mean people
know what they're seeing in their heart
of hearts go ahead and you could have
you could have stopped the truth teller
okay it would have been enough there but
you're going into Boston and you're on
TV and you've been a truth-teller as you
said and on social media you're very
popular there get at that game is
well-known there you're well-known so
you're gonna walk into Boston people
gonna walk up to you in the concourse
the TD Garden and buy your seats they're
gonna see you sitting there may be in
your cleveland cavalier jersey i don't
know there and you're going to say what
when you know Nick Wright sucks gets
hurled down for a listen I went to
Philly I have no beef with Philly but I
had the audacity when Carson Wentz went
down to say if you lose an MVP you can't
win a Super Bowl and at the beginning of
the playoffs I said there are five teams
in the NFC that can win the Super Bowl
Philly's not one of them and then I went
to the NFC Championship game with Chris
Carter sitting in a box the the Vikings
box essentially there and the crowd in
front of me started a Nick Wright sucks
chant at what the link in Philadelphia
I would imagine I'm much more disliked
in Boston yes and I was in Philadelphia
I've made sure of that I of course I
would also imagine people will be that
drunk or drunker because at least those
Eagles fans weren't preemptively
drinking away their sorrow Mother's Day
Sunday fans will be yeah but they know
they're in for two hours of pain yeah
like they know that
the last time LeBron lost to the Boston
Celtics in that arena in a playoff game
it was 2012
I do believe LeBron has more career
playoff victories in TD Garden than any
current member of the Boston Celtics so
I mean I mean listen people can heckle
me and I'm sure early in the game
they'll feel good about it and around
the third quarter
they'll sheepishly leave me alone as
Cleveland is dominating the game how
many games Cleveland win this series how
many games is Cleveland win will though
one for how many games do the mo in how
many games listen I it'll be to old
going back to Cleveland now does I think
they could get it stuff because I in
five maximum is the longest the series
will go on my eyes also the schedule
fell unfairly unluckily for Boston
because you have three days off between
games two and three so LeBron play
famously obviously all 82 this year and
the all-star game so didn't get a full
time off at the all-star break right
then he seven games in round one seven
exhausting game and then back to back
every day or every other day I should
say in round two so this is the freshest
he will have been all year going into
Game one and two quick turnaround going
into Game two but then three days off
going into Game three hey LeBron will
play 44 minutes a night if they need him
to and Boston didn't have an answer for
that
and Al Horford is 1 in 16 in his career
against LeBron again you love historical
context and I don't and it bit me in the
ass when I said in Toronto didn't didn't
have the same mental issues they did
after Game one I won but Al Horford and
we talked about this during the break Al
Horford in all his years has not had an
Aron Baynes playing alongside him Al
Horford in in Atlanta he had Paul
Millsap so he had to be the physical guy
and he's not the physical guy last year
in Boston he had a mere Johnson Al
Horford still had to be a more physical
guy now he's out there and he has aron
baynes aron baynes not gonna be able to
play man Tristan Thompson plays but
Tristan Thompson is not gonna start
they're gonna start with Kevin Love
they'll play Aaron veins out there look
Aron Baynes is it first of all he's an
excellent perimeter defender for a big
man he's an excellent permit offender
they will play Aron Baynes in this
series okay
listen either if you're relying on a big
aron baynes contribution then I then I I
rest my kills just just to to uh to
offset the physical stuff the horror
stuff I get it and it's odd Horford I
saw Horford go dominate Joel embiid he
ate Joel and beads lunch on both ends of
the court in this last round I believe
in b2b the second-best big man healthy
big man in the game behind Anthony Davis
Tristan Thompson's historically been a
really tough matchup for him Kevin
love's been a tough matchup for him in
the I mean I guess he wasn't even on the
team when your guy Kelly Olynyk ripped
out his shoulder when the Celtics in a
few years ago so I just it's it's odd
the matchups are weird
how did Kelly might become my guy but I
just figure I he's a Boston guy it's
figure II I figure if like there's a
Boston guy just here a few years ago you
were like where everything you just said
about aron baynes like hasn't faced a
guy like kelly olynyk
yeah let me tell you about it it's just
a new bar still with JJ Foley's so I
just I I think Boston
I thought Boston Lusa filling I though I
was wrong on I thought they'd lose to
Philly I thought Philly just had too
much talent that even if they were too
young and Philly at that point in time
was the hottest team in the NBA they'd
not only won 20 of 21 they had the
league's second best record since
Christmas day think about how longer
that was Philly just they got I it's
weird to say Philly could have won that
series 4-1 and they lost at 4-1 there
were 350 not even 50/50 games there are
three games that were 7525 Philly and
Brad Stevens and the Celtics out
executed and won them all I don't think
that will be the case in this round and
you know this this stat probably better
than me I'm gonna butcher it that's like
14 times this year the Celtics been down
at least 15 points and won the game yeah
something alone or something like that
they have had this belief if it's
closely we got it well nobody has that
belief more than LeBron and the Cavs
like that is that is the other crazy
thing that's happened this postseason is
the who hit the three oh ji-hun wahby on
an obeah pardon me hits the three to tie
the game in Toronto and it is like a Tom
Brady situation you look you're like oh
he left LeBron way too much time like
that's the level that he's playing at
they got no answer you've been coaching
matters in this series I did
because look Nate McMillan good coach I
don't consider Nate a great tactician in
the NBA Dwane Casey I don't consider him
a great tactician Brad Stevens has a
track record great tactician so the
bronze gonna see different looks I don't
know what they're gonna do with them I
don't know if they treat LeBron in the
same way they treated Yanis in Joel
embiid and say we're gonna let him get
what he gets and stop the 3-point
shooters but they're gonna have
different looks they're gonna have waves
of players to throw at him I think
coaching matters I think tyloo's an
underrated coach yes I think tyloo's
should get credit for sticking with
Kevin Love at the five I think ty lue
should get credit for dusting in the
mothballs all Tristan Thompson and I
think probably saving Tristan Thompson's
relationship with miss Kardashian
because well give him what he's done
she's certainly not staying with him if
he's not still famous and in the league
so I think there's a lot of things he
deserves credit for that people don't
necessarily recognize they don't want to
give credit for word because LeBrons
there but he's not as good of a coach as
Brad Stevens I would agree with you I
also think Stevens has a template about
how do we take the others the non LeBron
players out look at what Indiana did do
some of that look at what Toronto did do
none of that yep so I do think this is
gonna be I believe a series that
Cleveland wins in four or five that you
feel like man Boston could have been up
3-2 after you know what I mean that I do
think it'll be close games I was being a
little tongue-in-cheek earlier when I
was saying Game one
I think will be a blog I think Cleveland
will win I didn't Cleveland will win but
I think it's close games and Boston's
got bodies to throw at LeBron Marcus
Moore's taken for 10 minutes that your
guy is it you boo silly that are Shawn
yeah silly Sammy o shillin's the guy I'm
thinking of they're both built similar
but semi semi looks like an NFL tight
end yeah you you lean on him for 10
minutes Marcus smart who I consider like
a rich man's Lance Stephenson you go
breathe your I imagine bad breath on him
and lean on him and do those types of
things like that will the LeBron still
gets his but against Toronto it looked
like he was practicing and against
Indiana it looked like he had to work
for everything I think Boston will be
closer to that one of the reasons that
Boston does well against a team like
Golden State and Houston last couple of
years that played excellent to get the
moves and I want to talk
yeah they play great against those two
teams is because when you try to create
mismatches against Boston it doesn't
work because they'll switch everything
and they've got good defenders at key
positions if you just try to blow
through them it can work because you
know a guy like LeBron they don't have
an individual answer for a guy like
embiid well Bane's play pretty well
against him
they had answered Yanis had great
moments in this series LeBron is capable
in this series if he wants to to go for
40-plus every single night but is that a
winning formula in a series like this
because Nick I think if LeBron wants to
average 40 boss is gonna let him if they
can keep jr. Smith Kyle Korver and Kevin
Love from eating them up from beyond the
three-point line Boston's gonna take
their chances with that type of matching
yeah I here's the thing LeBron in I
think that was obviously the strategy in
round one against it the Indiana
strategy we're not gonna double him and
he still averaged eight assists a game
right and those guys weren't hitting
shots he could average 11 they guys were
just missing open shots in round and
round 1 LeBron averaged 34 10 and 8 in
round 2 he averaged 35 8 and 11 like his
performance has been relatively stable
the difference is the other guys I think
Kevin Love all of a sudden being back to
he was the first 30 games of the year is
wildly important for them not only in
this round but if they're gonna have
even a punter shot against what I
believe will be Houston I think the
world believes will be Golden State oh
you think it's Houston you're right the
world does still believe it's Golden
State who's the most important player in
that series James Harden James for the
series and for his own rep listen harden
the last four years you can put his
regular seasons against anybody Steph
Katy LeBron Russ anybody he he arguably
could have won two of the last maybe
even three of the last four MVPs
assuming he went to this one if he is a
no-show or plays poorly in this round no
one will ever care about him again like
that that seems extreme that seems
unfair
he will never be considered for MVP
again no matter what it is in the
regular season people don't want to
believe in it people don't like the
style in which he plays they think it's
herky-jerky which it is they think it
tricks the ref which made
maybe it does I I have tremendous
respect for what he's able to do
I think drawing fouls is a skill I think
his defense was unfairly maligned even
when it was bad because he had to carry
such a heavy offensive load but he's got
to go look like an MVP like if the
Rockets are going to win I think they
have to have the best player on the
court and you can say oh that's unfit
James Harden gonna be the league MVP
this year he should be able to be the
best player on the court as good as
katie is as good as Steph is and you
know from doing first things first with
me there's a number that I haven't
gotten over all year
playoffs included the Rockets have
played 55 games with harden cp3 and
Capello they are 50 and 5 in those games
that's a remarkable number and so I feel
like they can beat Golden State if they
play their best I think the Rockets at
their best would beat Golden State I
also met its best gold and say that its
best is an odd one because theoretically
at its best it means clay Katie and
Steph all at their very best I don't
think that's beatable right but I also
think that's not something that can
happen over seven games you know what I
mean I think the rock now you can you
can't ask three jump shooters to hit
jump shots for all seven games does that
make sense yeah I think Houston hat it's
almost a must win in Game one as odd as
that is like you worked so hard for home
court while Golden State Coast can't
confident Brent yeah it would just be so
mentally deflating if you lose Game one
one one going back to Golden State with
Houston having lost Game one compared to
having lost game two to me is just for
them mentally different at least in my
eye for let's ago Dwane Casey fired in
Toronto just happened for real real out
surprised can either traded DeRozan I'd
uh might not be an either-or sure
I just wow that's a brutal turn of
events for the guy makes me feel good
that he won that award from his fellow
coaches he's probably gonna win the
media award listen he's probably nine
wins matters like you're doing what they
did with that bench matters reinventing
things on the fly matter I so you can't
beat the greatest basketball player ever
like a that's not it's an unfair
standard and in an odd way if the Cavs
had remember that game against Philly
when Philly had a 30 point lead
Cleveland comes essentially all the way
back and loses that was the interesting
Cleveland being the three seed in the
foresee if Cleveland to the three seat
and Toronto's and play them till the
Conference Finals does he get fired even
if they get sweat like it's because of
the round in which they had to play them
and so the reason I say I had trade
DeRozan is unless it's Stefan clay I
haven't seen the template of your two
best players being in your back court
you win a title my wall and Beal are not
gonna work it's why Lillard and McCollum
have a ceiling oh the Houston would work
if I mean they're sure I guess that
would be an example if it happened that
that team is that team is you let me
maybe rephrase it one of them's got to
be an MVP even right just like it wasn't
Golden State you can argue the bat I
would argue the two best players on the
bad boy Pistons where Isiah and just
like the collective frontcourt toughness
but Isiah was an MVP caliber player like
DeRozan was awesome this year but he has
a ceiling like let me let me ask you
real quick would you do DeRozan for
boogie if no for mothers I my greater
concern with boogie is that what does he
play like without the carrot of a
contract in front of him I mean he does
he go back to being the guy we saw in
Sacramento who was kind of fat and
content and I used that figuratively not
literally or does he continue to be a
hungry guy we've seen over there are
going to be some great coach quotes
about Dwane Casey getting fired yeah
Popovich gonna somebody track down Stan
Van Gundy he's still good well Stan Van
Eyck Carlile will say something wild
Popovich that's tough for Dwayne Casey
man but I listen I Toronto eyes I think
Masai Ujiri for years has wanted to hire
his own guy anyway remember sighs been
there forever but he inherited Dwayne
Casey and they have got a good a
relationship and an improved
relationship over the years but I think
Masai like any GM has won to hire his
own guy the question is who's the blue
chip guy out there like who was the guy
that gladdens that's the argument
everyone fires coaches I I what there
are closer to there's almost a dozen
teams in the NBA that's unfair eight
teams in the NBA that are kneecapped by
their coach that have a terrible awful
coaching
I believe the
box had to this year just coaches that
and maybe that's unfair to the to the
interim guy Prunty but he you he wasn't
helping them and Jason Kidd certainly
wasn't helping them you fired Wayne
Casey you might end up with an
incompetent there is not a surplus of
quality coaches in this league and by
the way I I don't think no in case to be
unemployed for long we will get a job
he's a good coach man you know who they
get maybe they go on getting Mike
Budenholzer who was best known last as
getting broomed up by LeBron the
playoffs with Atlanta for him I mean
it's Adam to the graveyard Nick great to
see you man I have the great work on
first things first fs1 every Thursday
our viewers every day 6:30 to 9:30 a.m.
Eastern Time thanks Tom thank you so
much it's not going to be on here
appreciated for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]